3 à 3,5 pour cent le paiement minimum
mensuel des cartes de crédit augmente
une fois de plus ouais y'a pas de payer
à chaque mois qu'est ce qu'il faut c'est
normal non je suis content vraiment
l'augmentation parce que je trouve qu'on
appelle déjà beaucoup si une chose monde
2.5 pour ça ça vaut mais tout change de
point 5% depuis 135 cas pas ça c'est là
où on voit vraiment l'impact et les gens
sont déjà surendettés de ce qu'on entend
fait que ces jeux sont un poids
supplémentaire le pouvoir d'achat
diminue concrètement qu'est ce que ça
change une personne avec un solde de
carte de crédit à 1000 $ qui paient
trois pour cent du solde ne devait
rembourser que 30 dollars par mois à 3,5
pour cent elle devra maintenant
rembourser 35 soit une différence de 5
dollars par mois ces ajustements
s'inscrivent parmi les mesures adoptées
en 2017 par l'assemblée nationale du
québec vous prévenir les problèmes
d'endettement et les paiements minimums
augmenteront d'année en année 2 points 5
point de pourcentage pour atteindre 5 %
en 2025 une hausse qui devrait inciter
les ménages à rembourser plus vite leur
dette note cet expert en insolvabilité
je pense qu'en général favorable pour
les jeunes est ce une forme de dépenses
obligatoires rembourser ses dettes d'une
façon plus rapide mais qui arrive à un
moment où tout coûte plus cher et où les
budgets sont déjà serré 70% de ses
clients dit il s'oriente vers des
propositions aux consommateurs pour
arriver à rembourser leurs dettes la
classe moyenne je rayon des dates des
crédits en 15 m $
donc c'est sûr quand même un minimum à
chaque mois
à 3 4% ça peut affecter leur budget au
niveau liquidités
mais ça les forces à rembourser en
partie capitale avant quand c'était 2%
les gens payés parce majos l'intérêt se
tourner vers les compagnies de cartes de
crédit elle même est aussi une solution
à l'endettement pour cette chercheuse il
y aurait aussi une manière d'agir en
forçant les compagnies de cartes emv
digne de changer leurs comportements
d'ici là certains préfèrent rester loin
de ce mode de paiement j'ai comme
lors de mes dépenses donc je fais très
attention aux sacs le paiement prévu
pour toute nouvelle carte de crédit lui
reste inchangé au minimum de 5% ici
daniel k jaws radio canada montréal